hey everyone diavolo here and today we
are diving back into juicy Kaizen and
the current Beatdown that is going on
between two of the universe's strongest
Fighters yes this is the decisive
Saturday Gojo vs ryoming sakuna battle
and the uninhabited demon-invested
District of Shinjuku or at least you
know everything that's kind of out so
far who knows how long this flight's
actually going to go on for nothing that
I could think of throughout the series
but maybe the sakuna vs maharaga battle
even comes close to the scale of cursed
energy consumption or destruction that
we'd be a witness to here this is truly
an amazing fight to behold and
encapsulates everything that makes Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen so freaking good so if you
are new around here make sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with all of
you to Kaizen and if you do enjoy the
video make sure to leave a like and try
and help push this video to 5K likes so
that I know you're all interested and
want to see more stuff just like this
but either way sit back and relax as we
watch Shinjuku get wiped from reality
well I guess I need to kind of take
everything back to the exact moment
where they fight kicked off and of
course massive manga spoilers for anyone
who's an anime only and having to
stumble across this fight anyhows as all
of these Sorcerers were lacking out
discussing how to give Gojo a boost of
confidence as as the first time they've
ever really needed to do so Gojo himself
accompanied by Gramps and utahime or
with looks of determination then roll up
and get ready for battle with everyone
around filling his Aura Yuji great to
Sensei wholeheartedly and lets him know
that he can't even get close because his
technique's in the way goju is slightly
surprised by this but after a moment
ends up laughing while telling his boy
to give it to him causing Yuji to jump
up and slap his Sensei on the back then
falling on the same path every other
sorcerer padded Gojo on the back as he
rolled through the group on his way to
the battlefield walking through a
skyscraper with Gojo now ajichi knows
that it feels like ages since he was
last here yet in reality it's only been
just over a month now wanting to know
what like the realm felt like Gojo
explains to him that the prison realm
was like when you're mad busy with work
that it flashes in a week however the
feeling's so draining that you'd never
want to experience it again after a few
moments Gojo inquires about the people
in the basement of shibuyu's metro
station where all of that chaos had
started back in the Shibuya incident Arc
if like we're being specific that's
where Gojo came across choso Hanami and
jogo and they tried you know like
teaming up on him and whatnot even
though Gojo only fought them for a very
short period of time at least for
imminent of Gojo's cursed energy that
made cursed Spirit avoid the entire
floor which is actually insane when you
think about it like this man is so
strong his residuals managed to secure
off curse Spirits which is I just I
still can't feather mode like I don't
think anyone else is on this level
ajichi also reveals that the people who
were affected by a 0.2 second domain are
all fine and those who were affected
return to normal walking it behind
Gramps in utahime now Atop The growth
Gojo and ajichi arrive as the Day of
Reckoning has begun elsewhere a roommate
asks what time the fight is going to
take place twitch sakuna reveals that
they didn't really specify a time but as
he says that he's able to feel Gojo's
Aura emanating in his Direction back in
the whole way and just moments before
they made it up to the roof a gichi
confronted Gojo on why he always wanted
him to construct the barriers for him
turning back and looking at his close
friend Gojo tells them that it's because
he trusts him more than anyone else now
atop the roof and slamming his hands
onto the ground in preparation for his
barrier ajichi just thinks on how he's
someone who's always fled no someone who
didn't even have the courage to flee and
was given the courage to run by a friend
despite everything ajiji braces himself
and knows that he must live up to Gojo's
expectations either that or die trying
in front of the two and while using her
curse technique called solo forbidden
Arena it's explained that any Sorcerer
of her choosing including usahime
herself will have the accursed energy
reserves and output temporarily enhanced
as long as they remain within range to
excel at Jiu Jitsu is to excel at
subtraction the degree to which a
sorcerer can admit Cadence movement and
other elements that relate to their
curse technique determines their skill
and ujahime leaves nothing else words
gestures dance music elevating these
simple techniques that of a ritual
boosts its Effectiveness by 120 percent
udahime's curse technique allows you to
boost the chosen sorcerer's curse in a g
and as Gojo himself also began chanting
to add to his own technique nine ropes
polarized light Crow and declaration
between front and back as revealed that
just like a girl Gojo has also never
left anything out and with the
combination of the Trio's curse in G he
shoots four his 200 Hollow purple as
goju's ability blasts forth sakuna
manages to take notice of it and throws
up his hands trying to block the entire
attack with the buildings all around him
exploding due to hollow purple sakuna's
defenses are undoubtedly breached as the
building he was standing on is
completely demolished causing it to fall
to the ground below uramae who was like
next to sukuna at the time of the attack
has also not been seen since this moment
so like correct me if I'm wrong on that
or anything but after this moment she's
seemingly vanished from reality so if
she's either gone or she sneaked off
managing to like survive that attack
probably healing up somewhere either way
as these smoke slowly Fades it's made
evident that Judah and jichi's barrier
sakuna actually misread Gojo's first
move like even though he knew where he
was he didn't sense the insane curse
energy output until the last moment
bursting through the smoke sukuna with
one least hand somehow managed to tank
the first attack leaving the true battle
between history and today's strongest
Sorcerers to continue so skipping back
just before the blast sakuna and uramae
were located at the Shinjuku Center
which is around four to five kilometers
away from the Shibuya building Gojo was
currently on with his team having
strolled or probably just teleported
across that distance in a matter of
moments Gojo sets the record straight
and tells the king of curses that he's
the Challenger here the Challenger
though sukoon is standing there finds it
a sleep pathetic that goja would State
there after landing a surprise attack in
his eyes and as he brings his hands
together Gojo is no more than a fish
atop his chopping board one slightly
fresher but still a nameless fish flew
clearing up his curse energy sukuna just
remarks that it's time he starts peeling
back Gojo scales Gojo asks him why he's
still wearing that face and guesses that
sakuna's original thought was to steal
megami's body so he'd hold back during
the fight unfortunately for him how
man's been through a specific set of
training that allows him to go all out
on anyone who resembles any sort of
resemblance to the great toji fushiguro
considering that Gojo himself trained
Megami he probably knows exactly how
many hits this student could take before
he dies and given that sakuna had
survived death while possessing juji's
body God you thought it would be prudent
to only start worrying about migami's
welfare after he kills the person in
control initiating the conflict the duo
darted each other both just narrowly
dodging each successive strike dropping
to the floor just out of range of sakona
goju flicks out his hands straight into
his opponent's nut sending them shooting
under the side of a nearby building and
out the other side crashing into some
stairs behind it getting up he's
instantly harassed by Gojo who stomping
in his Direction proceeds to kick him in
the gut so he's perfectly placed in the
middle of an overpass Bridge platform
continuing to stomp down Gojo collects
as the platform sukuna was on making his
footing extremely unstable taking the
opportunity to catch him off guard goes
your activates his infinity and
levitates the bridge into the sky before
tossing it directly as a large
skyscraper resisting the force of the
platform sukuni uses dismantle or what I
assume to be dismantled to cause this
structure to collapse then making it
over to a nearby roof in the flesh of an
eye sakuna pulls up his hand and sends a
massive slice using dismantle to cut the
building directly behind Gojo in half
while they are man turning around to
look at it zakuna quickly rushes him
thrown a fat right Hawk that catches
Gojo off guard however as the punch
connects with his Infinity he decides to
deactivate his technique in order to
physically take sakuna inside of the
collapsing structure following him up
the hallway Gojo quickly opened the door
for a moment that blinds the two from
seeing exactly what ability they're
about to throw at each other catching
them both off guard though the building
crashes into the ground below bringing
their previously intense fight to a
brief pause walking out of the debris
will all of these smoke slowly started
to disperse got your jokes that well
he's just gonna pin all of this
destruction on sakona once he gets out
of here sakuna though points out that he
really can't say anything quickly making
Gojo realize that man-made is actually
streaming this entire fight to the world
also I just want to cut myself off for a
moment to say thank you to everyone who
watches my content from the hardcore
goated patreon to have helped me with
like extra cash to find editors which is
now like allowed with weekly uploads to
just the Casual viewers for the support
down in the comment section we're about
to finally hit 170 000 Subs now and I
truly never expected such a dope little
Community to spawn from these stories I
make if you do want more content from me
not that it's like brand new content or
anything it's kind of rehashed I do have
a second Channel and watch every file
I've talked about in my larger videos at
the six hour and eight hour ones and
stuff as getting re-uploaded there I've
also got a Discord down below which I go
leave and everything same with the other
channel and which I usually release
spoilers for jiu jitsu Kaizen and kind
of just hang out in the chat there and
talk with people from time to time so
that's stuff all down below like I just
said but again thank you for 170 000
subscribers but let's get back into this
video and hands that repair to witness
either way when it comes down to Gojo's
Limitless technique it allows him to be
completely Untouchable to get around
this and in a similar way to what Hanami
and jogo did sakuna is using domain
amplification to neutralize his curse
technique confuse slightly on what
domain amplification is he explains to
everyone while they watch the fight that
he saw something similar in makamaru's
footage he pretty much said like what I
exactly said before about Joko and an
army using domain amplification to
nullify like Gojo's technique and
everything Curry points out that it does
seem like Gojo's domain has been
neutralized but he's still confused how
the old G kusakabe lets them all know
that it's more of a refined version of a
simple domain if one sheaths himself in
a domain without imbuing your own curse
technique he'll allow the opponent's
technique to flow into that empty space
thereby neutralizing it Angel points out
that the main drawback to domain
amplifications is that you can't
simultaneously use your own internet
Technique No One not even sukona is an
exception to this rule so and her eyes
if sukuna has another way to deal with
lump unless other than domain amp then
Gojo will 100 lose confused on whether
don't just use the domain expansion
maybe what inquires as to why she knows
that immediately following the domain
once technique becomes unstable so oh my
God so it would make sense for sukuna to
challenge your domain first Carrara
notes that it is easy to say there but
depending on the outcome of that domain
battle the fights would be over which
and both of the girl's eyes is the
correct battle strategy Yuji though
having been told something by Gojo
reveals that he's pretty sure the domain
sure heard effect negates Gojo's
technique to begin with hooking up wee
wee wonders if it's because sukuna
doesn't think he can win in a domain
expansion against Gojo still Shoku
points out that yeah you are right but
goju probably would have opened one if
that was the case so she finds it hard
to believe that Gojo wouldn't be able to
foresee that as well standing near chosu
Ponders the question of what would
happen if God George domain did clash as
from what he was told sakuna's domain as
a burialist domain here in this bizarre
statement every everyone just reacts in
shock unable to believe that his domain
doesn't even have a barrier as an
example of like just how impossible this
is kusakabe asks me what to toss on that
water however after she gives him the
bottle he throws it back telling her to
give him the water not the bottle
confused maybe we'll just facials the
absolute hell out of kuzakabe while and
behind him Mason explains they're
expanding their domain without a barrier
it's like trying to hold water without a
bottle with no container can you even
accumulate water can you paint on thin
air without a canvas with no stem roots
or leaves can a flower bloom from a seed
Maggie Compares it to using software
without even having a PC to run anything
on it's frankly unfathomable in their
eyes it's completely impossible even
still she notes that mikh muslimane
wasn't even enclosed within a barrier
and having heard that before Mega
Millions given his great promotion
kusakave explained that he used it he
actually had to use an existing
structure to enclose his domain Naruto
shikamo or like as we know him now can
was able to pull it off by himself so it
does prove that it can happen choso who
actually fought during that battle
pointed out that they're prepared to use
a simple domain on hinjaku while tenkin
dismantled his domain from the outside
however because of the burialist domain
it was the simple domain that was torn
apart miwa who's confused over what
exactly would Clash in the slight attack
states that the short effect is imbued
within the barrier itself so it could
only clash with another barrier she also
realizes that well everyone's talking as
if their domains are a given but domains
devour an insane amount of curse energy
so wouldn't avoiding using them make
sense and yumaki speaks up and notes
that well it doesn't really matter since
Gojo has an infinite amount of curse
energy in your nose hit that like fact
isn't actually true and it's just due to
how he's skilled at using his specific
technique everscus energy consumption
rate ends up being less than what he
actually replenishes then it could
technically run out that's just working
under the assumption though that he's
using it like normal if he changes
things up and starts to using domains
consecutively then they could be
completely different story now I haven't
even mentioned what sakuna is actually
capable of as well in fighting kashimu
speaks up to state that the sharpness of
his techniques activation is
unparalleled the way you can switch
things up in a matter of milliseconds
from innate techniques to domain
amplifications is utterly amazing if
Gojo literally wasn't who he is then
sakuna would comfortably be winning in
terms of cursed energy utilization
what's more his total curse energy
output is probably even more than yota's
from what he can physically tell he'd
say it's probably double the amount that
he actually has Momo who's been pretty
quiet this entire chat speaks up and
feels that maybe nobody not even them
knows how this is going to play out if
Gojo and tsukunu's domains do Clash who
knows what could possibly happen then
right on that exact moment and after all
of this insane build up that we just
went through make a rumor signal that
they are about to begin the domain
clashes back in Shinjuku bosukuna and
Gojo throw up their respective hand
signs to simultaneously open the
infinite 4
now appearing above his Shrine and Gojo
standing a few feet back it's explained
that the two are evenly matched they
form a perfect pair within Gojo's
barrier which in turn meant they both
guaranteed hits overlapped each other
then canceled themselves owls in this
battle and as the two expand their
domains should either one of them
sustain severe damage it will cause the
collapse of their domain and the other
ones sure hats will immediately take
effect back at the TV room kuzakabe and
meimei both reacts in shock as somehow
even with their domains active they're
still evenly matched and Shinjuku the
pure force of the two overlapping
domains caused the surrounding area to
start getting atomized sadly for Gojo
the effective range of sukuna's domain
reaches even beyond their of a barrier
and just as Eugene knows that a domain
expansion is weak from the outside
goji's domain cracks and shatters as
it's shown that below it sukunu's domain
now sit perfectly fine with no
protection against the kona's short head
technique the effect immediately flies
forth and seemingly cuts down the
strongest Sorcerer of today having taken
the slash to the neck Gojo nonchalantly
activates his reverse curse technique
watch everyone Becca the layer reacts
too hegaruma states that as long as Gojo
stays in range his slashes will never
stop coming chosu who assumes escaping
is probably the Port of Call for Gojo is
backed up by hakari who someone agreed
with him however it's more that Hikari
assumes Gojo will make a dash for the
exit whereas kusakave realizes the
teleporting is out of the question since
it's an application of a limitless
technique due to the use of his domain
expansion and it being destroyed it's
plausible that for a moment he can't use
his curse technique which like they
State means he's in store for one hell
of a beat down back inside of sakuna's
domain expansion Gojo is relentlessly
slashed over and over again by the short
head effect of the domain somehow though
Gojo manages to calm himself as he knows
for a fact that when it comes down to
techniques Limitless is far better
having been able to consistently
overpower sukuna's short head effect
with his use of reverse cursive
technique Gojo just like what everyone
else had expected make it a dash for the
excerpt sukuna immediately makes a dash
to keep up with him while remarking that
he isn't going to just let him Escape
grabbing his leg though Gojo still will
constantly getting slashed pulls him in
and nasakuna into the floor towering
over him got your attempts to learn a
curse energy infused overhand but misses
only cracking the floor as jakuna
manages to quickly weasel his way out
standing there and looking at his
opponent sukunu remarks that Gojo's
still moving pretty well considering
that he's been activating his reverse
curse technique at full output in order
to survive the constant slashing Gojo on
the other hand notices something
extremely important to him it looks like
malevolent Shrine itself is the heart of
the domain not sakona back inside of the
headquarters Yuji Ponders what would
happen if someone did destroy the heart
of the domain or like the shrine
specifically the big ring kuzakabe
brings up their objects inside of
domains don't tend to hold any special
meaning or significance so think of it
as like it wasn't even there to begin
with Mason thinks that if it is a symbol
of the domain then you wouldn't even be
able to destroy it and even considering
Gojo's insane skills it doesn't look
like he's taken any measures to actually
try to destroy it suddenly Gojo
activates the new Shadow style simple
domain taking kusakaya Bay by surprise
as he probably didn't expect to see this
one Yuji though noted that Gojo said one
time he could use it but wasn't able to
actually teach her during the battle he
was able to use the simple domain to
counter the short head effect while
simultaneously using reverse acoustic
neck to heal its body confused Yuji
wonders how one even manipulates their
own curse energy while reverse curse
technique is active again Gojo activates
another use of this simple domain before
dating at sakuna and attempted to strike
him in an instant he's once again
pounded by the shorehead effect layering
Gojo with a plethora of cuts though
again he activates another use of simple
domain and reverse curse technique
causing sakona to call us all a little
bit tedious right now randomly though
everyone back at the headquarters is
taken by surprise when they see Gojo
started attacking sakona once more with
without using reverse Cruise technique
to heal himself someone wonders if he's
running low on Curious energy but Yoda
refutes this as it's it's frankly
impossible there's no limit to go just
curse energy even though it totally is
speaking up though Eno mentions that
like he said before the Assumption rate
could currently be off right after
domain expansion he started using
reverse curse technique and maximum
output which uses up twice as much curse
energy and that's not even taken into
account the fact that sakuna is also
rushing at Gojo himself with the two
powerhouses of this series also rushing
at each other once again and he cuts not
stopping for Gojo everyone wonders if
Gojo is about to lose jumping onto Kona
though and raping his hands around the
back of his head Gojo activates his
curse technique reversal before leaning
back and pulling his hands up in
preparation to end the fights Blown Away
with what he's just witnessed you'd
wonders if it's even possible in his
mind the reason he wasn't able to heal
himself for a moment was because Gojo
was using reverse acoustic knee to heal
his exhausted cursed technique
unleashing red goju shoots forth a blast
of reverse curse technique propelling
sakuna back into the shrine that makes
up the center of his domain noting that
like he somehow managed to survive the
blast goju activates reverse curse
technique to heal and jokes that damn
this toot is really turning into a pain
on the ass going into like more depth on
the insane fate Gojo just did you do her
explains that acoustic neck which has
been burned out by using domain
expansion as an entirely different
matter than physical damage it's like
when a machine overheads if it isn't
broken you have to let it cool down or
it won't work again interpreting this
Maki makes it easier to understand by
saying that reverse curse technique can
repair damage but it can't help with the
cooling effects of Earth however it
looks as if this understanding of the
ability is completely wrong back in
Shinjuku and having made it out of the
effective range Gojo asks that sukuna is
able to expand the size of his area not
even giving Gojo a second to thank
sukuna until he expands the size of
malevolent shrine's domain expansion to
its maximum in this same moment Gojo to
the shock of every everyone also
expanded his infinite void for a second
time with everyone watching they wonder
if God is really dumb enough to just
fall into the same trip as before May
notices at first though and Higa Roma
who by the way like for a new sorcerer
is so big brain state that Goku switched
conditions on the external and internal
conditions of his barrier which and
simple enough terms for myself and Yuji
to understand means that goju this time
is able to protect himself against the
attacks from outside of his domain
re-initiate any better once more both
Gojo and sukuna trade hands back and
forth but not once really hurts actually
end up landing on either side jumping
back Gojo is absolutely blown away as he
understands that somehow sukunu was able
to use his domain expansion and
amplification at the exact same time on
top of that he's becoming more
comfortable inside of his own infinite
void and his curse energy output is only
increasing so unusual Jujutsu Kai is in
combat you cannot use internet technique
that is etched into your body while
using a domain amp but if you go in and
imbue your domain with a technique
itself then this is an entirely new
situation throw any punch sakuna manages
to dodge back out of the way however as
he pushes trying to strike Dojo the six
size Maniac manages to evade the strike
and thump the side of sakuna's body
managing to spin out of Gojo's sight he
quickly understands that somehow and
while inside of his own domain zakuna
turned off his short head effect knowing
that the only ones who are unaffected by
infinite void are Gojo and anyone he
touches sukuna's plan is to expand his
effective range and increase the power
of The Binding vowel even further than
he did in Shibuya with mega Me by using
a binding vowel sukuna is able to
further increase the power of His domain
outside of Gojo's domain he does that by
removing his short hit guarantee inside
of the domain or simultaneously also
keeping himself safe from infinite void
by touching Gojo due to all of this and
again just like last time Gojo's domain
collapses and the man is followed by
plethora of strikes that seemingly knock
him away from sakona with everyone back
at the like the TV station he caught his
place whatever it honestly is I don't
have a clue what to even call it
reacting horror to what's going on in
the current battle how do you most stay
instead of Gojo dies here he's going out
to fight next so don't even try and stop
him over in Shinjuku Gojo activates
another technique that he notes he
hasn't used much since he mastered his
domain seeing this kusakabe spits out of
smoke in awe of just having the same
Gojo use the falling Blossom emotion for
those of you who forgot because I think
it's only being used like maybe two or
three times throughout the series it's a
secret art of The Big Three Families an
anti-domain technique all in all it's an
application of curse energy that
automatically repels anything you touch
it wouldn't even be able to do something
against the complex domain like infinite
void but if you're up against something
like simple slashes it's pretty useful
jumping in Shoku says that he most
likely used it so he can heal his burned
out curse technique or at the least buy
some time again though like what is this
the third time now Gojo blows them all
away as he activates another use of
infinite void and like all of the pre
previous uses though this time it's
completely massive in comparison and
akashimo's eyes it looks as if Gojo was
trying to encapsulate all of sukuna's
domain within his own barrier May thinks
that it's a bad move trying to expand
her domain to that size as it'll
drastically lower its Effectiveness and
like her guruma State even if the domain
isn't destroyed as still pointless
unless he wins the battle inside of it
suddenly Gojo's domain cracks putting
everyone on edge and making them think
that it's about to fail Momo though
quickly speaks up that no it's not
broken in fact the barrier is quickly
changing in size and now it's only a
fraction of the original size with
gochu's domain only like the size of a
basketball now because it can't be
remarked this is this is frankly
impossible was he made to joke about how
many times they've said these words
today Marky curiously questions its
outward appearance and if the inside is
dead of a similar size kusakabi agrees
with her as that's why when you're
usually trapped inside one you can't get
out unless you find the edge of the
barrier even if you find their Edge a
normal domain is resistant to attacks on
the outside wide so Escape is still
extremely limited what's most important
when it comes to a barrier technique is
a concrete image usually if you try and
envision a barrier too small enough to
hold yourself and an opponent it would
just collapse just like the prison realm
though and probably due to his time
being confined in a small space there as
now allowing Gojo to take that and
implement it into his domain during the
battle still kuzakabe can't grasp the
process around how he's able to change
the conditions of his domain each time
he uses it barriers particularly domain
barriers typically have a set of
internal and external parameters by
discovering their own blend of these
parameters every sorcerer is able to
establish their own domain confused and
piping their heads up as obviously this
wasn't how Higa Roma and Hikari figured
out their domains like they open their
domains by default as a part of the
occurs technique in any case they aren't
usually things that can be changed
easily kuzuki Ponders if he changed the
size of his domain because it was too
difficult to maintain the larger surface
Mass so we had to compress it to make
things easier or maybe it was because he
wanted to see if you could cover all of
the malevolent Shrine with an even
larger barrier with goyo's domain
beginning to shake back and forth at
such a tremendous speed the Earth itself
begins to rumble May points out that
even still Gojo's domain has managed to
hold a new to state that zakuna has also
decreased his domain so he could
increase the output of his curse
technique so pretty much now if this
version of Gojo's barrier does end up
breaking they'll enter a stalemate
however Gojo will actually end up being
on the back foot as he will run out of
options technique wise flashing back
over to Shinjuku sadly once more Gojo's
domain is getting shattered and tsukuna
emerges Victorious for a third time in
the domain struggle it's it's either the
third or the fourth now I'm honestly
losing track throughout the script here
having watched his Sensei reappear Yuji
screams out for him however in that
moment all of the other sorcerers are
flabbergasted as they witness the kona's
malevolent Shrine start to crumble and
fall to pieces on top of that it's shown
that at some point throughout the domain
struggle Gojo was able to lend a clean
blow so they chest of sakona causing the
king of curses to finally take some
proper damage seeing this over their
monitors all of these Sorcerers scream
and joy believing that goju still has a
chance to win in this battle funnily
enough it was actually simultaneous at
the exact same time zakuna destroyed
Goku's domain from the outside Gojo had
actually destroyed sakuna's domain to
the point that he wasn't able to
maintain it any longer yelling at miwa
kusakabe asks if she was able to keep
track of what's going on in this fight
or if anyone kept track of the time that
Gojo's barrier was active speaking up
Mei reveals that it was active for three
minutes and nine seconds but if it was
more specifically after the moment that
it was minimized then that was exactly
three minutes hegaruma believes that now
the domains have collapsed neither of
them will be able to use the curse
techniques anymore if that is the case
Marky thinks Gojo can make the first
move since he can restore his burnt out
curse technique just like he did before
but sadly sukuna can also do the same
with reverse curse technique and
speaking of himself now that he knows
how it works you know theorizes that he
could probably do it too though like he
mentioned earlier it can't be used to
heal a burnt out curse technique but it
actually can he's just like he's just
tripping right now the reasoning that
Gojo actually showing this to sakona is
a terrible problem for everyone is
because back in the past zakuna was able
to split his Spirit 20 times into 20
different objects called zakuna's cursed
fingers after seeing this ability just
once in the past zakuna learned how to
turn himself into a cursed object and
now that he's seen this new ability it's
most likely he'll also be able to
restore his burnt out curse technique
and Shinjuku so couldn't boost his way
out onto a bridge giving a moment of
pace before noticing that random parts
of the road start to get smashed up from
below quickly jumping off the bridge and
onto some railing nearby secunda notices
Gojo break his way up through the brick
behind him then turning back around
realizes that his Escape rope was
blocked by a ball of rocks that Gojo had
perfectly floated there using his
Infinity with absolutely nowhere to go
saguna throws up his hands to block
block and takes a kick that seems I'm
sliding back along the sidewalk taking a
moment to think about the fight got your
wonders why sakuna has been stubbornly
avoiding using any other curse technique
than his own even when the strength of
the barrier was lowered and Gojo had
flipped the conditions on it he didn't
try to destroy it from the inside
instead he took the riskier option while
they canceled out each other's short
head effects from within the domain
scooter had no other choice but to use
his domain amplification in order to
beat his Limitless curse technique which
was actually a massive Advantage for our
man still as he saw earlier within a
domain sukuna is unable to use buildings
to attack in fact until after Gojo's
domain was destroyed he technically had
the upper hand for over three minutes
yet in spite of that he can't seem to
understand why sukuna didn't ever
attempt to make use of something from
the 10 Shadows technique or maharaga
while in a domain he has the memory of
Mega me and the conversation that
happened between them so he knows for a
fact that someone of the exact same
power died to a person like Mega me goju
just Ponders if he's scared he'll beat
my ragger in one shot however in that
exact same moment the wheel turned and
blood begins to drip from his own nose
nosebleed though God you was
baiting out damn ass with that one and
in an instant both him and sakona throw
up their hands and reform another domain
Clash yuju points out that again they
activated it at the exact same time an
angel who's right next to him brings up
there's a Kona can now restore his burnt
out curse technique or maybe just
decided to hide the fact that he could
until now because Bobby knows that
within the next three minutes that
actually takes a Kona to destroy kojo's
domain from the outside Gojo will need
to damage the kuna City point he can't
maintain his domain from the inside
shoko joking that they probably
shouldn't talk as if Gojo was on the
back foot yet brings up that if sakuna
is hit At All by unlimited void then man
is completely done for due to this it's
Susan that if Gojo was able to destroy
the malevolent Shrine within the next
three minutes then he will win this
battle inside of Shinjuku and having
freed up his cursed energy fists goju
pounds tsukuna with a barrage of punch
that really only Brews the king of
Kirsten's arms jumping up sakuna tries
to quickly get over his Shrine however
he's knocked into the floor then while
incapacitated is grabbed by Gojo's
infinity and pulled towards himself
having been flung towards Gojo sukuna
just manages to block a devastating
stomach punch randomly though and I'm
assuming man's used like yuji's
Divergent punch to delay the like hit of
his cursed energy sukuni's malevolent
Shrine is completely destroyed while in
the exact same moment Gojo's domain also
ends falling to the ground and looking
up as evident that this time zakuna took
a serious blow as half of his face
appears to be missing with everyone
believing that when it comes down to
domain struggles Goji was Stronger they
all hope deeper than themselves that he
can when beckon the battle and throwing
a fat right hook Goku have seen sukuna
straight back into the side of a bridge
pillar breaking it in the process I
don't know I don't even know what we're
at now like this is utterly insane and
in that moment gocho and zakuna launch
another set of domain struggles yet
unlike all of the previous battles
something is actually different here for
the first time and Utah can't help but
feel like maybe just maybe Gojo was able
to expand his domain earlier inside of
the domain's trouble it is revealed that
zakuna was indeed busy healing his body
and because of that it was late
restoring his curse technique it was
less than 0.01 seconds but unlimited
void landed on him as an infinite set of
infinite information rushes into the
cerebral cortex of History's Strongest
Sorcerer And the king of curses El man
today's current demon rushes forth and
pierces the chest of Darkness incarnate
only 2 minutes and 40 seconds after they
expanded their domains Gojo was able to
collapse malevolent Shrine within his
innate compound with nothing not even
the friction in the ear available for
zakone as you use now he stands there
dumbfounded as the full effects of
saturno Gojo's infinite Foy connects
with its brain not done yet himself Gojo
lets everyone know that crushing his
heart was only the beginning now he's
gonna take every everything from him
however before he's able to even connect
with sakona a set of prolific words are
spoken with this treasure I summon
eight-handled sword Divergent silly
Divine General maharaga skirting out
with the fact that like sukuna managed
to summon him in that moment because you
just assumes that it hasn't had time to
adapt to unlimited void yet so surely he
could destroy it and won shorts
activating curse technique reversal Gojo
is just baffled when he Witnesses
maharaga literally not Kia and instead
with this sort of extermination slashes
down completely destroying Gojo's
infinite void falling to the ground now
Gojo can only gasp as he realizes that
somehow Maharaja had already adapted to
his domain expansion allowing him to
freely attack from the inside realizing
that maharaga had been summoned Joseph
points out that it has the ability to
adapt to any attack even unlimited void
using reverse curse technique and with
maharaga by his side sakuna knows that
Gojo was well aware of the sugargami's
abilities any battle so far are both of
you guys have had their domains cancel
each other's out a total of five times
go to a short head effect targeted
everything within their domain whereas
succonus your head effect targeted
everything inside the domain with the
exception of himself this means that
this short had effect targeting sukuna
was still in place crazily enough one of
the duo was able to take on unlimited
void a total of five times we'll walk
shouldering the burden of maharaga's
adaption this person wasn't sukuna
though no it was someone else entirely
bombing away with the Revelation Gojo
quickly figures that somehow he managed
to adapt to unlimited void within 0.01
seconds of his domain opening doing some
more crazy deductions he figures that
like I said somehow Sakura overcame the
burden of maharaja's adaption ability
then realizing his wrong state that the
one actually take any damage was
migami's Soul deep inside the conscious
of migami's mind we see him barely awake
with maharaga's wheel floating directly
above him seeing goji now and wondering
what's on his mind sukuna asks what's up
twitch Gojo says nothing really it just
warms us hard to see him using such
fraudulent abilities replying to his
underhandedness Schooner states that
unlimited void is an ability that Gojo
activated once inside of his domain he
originally expected it to be a pain in
the ass trying to figure out this
technique and at the start of the fight
he had planned to neutralize it first so
while unable to use amplification within
the domain sukunu used mikami salt to
adapt to unlimited void using his own
tin Shadows technique as a result he
wasn't able to use anything other than
what was originally imbued into his own
domain knowing that origami took then
was the process of adaption not led the
full effect of infinite void itself goju
begins pulling up his hand and remarking
the tsukuna has an actually adapted Mega
me soul itself to unlimited void and if
he opens his domain once more he'll
destroy him in one attack not phased
over this though sukuna kinda just
laughs and taunts Gojo while telling him
that he's no longer able to open his
domain instantly and as he tries
activating it once more I'd begin
streaming from his nose and everyone
back at headquarters still watching new
monitors begins freaking out over the
possible outcomes by the way who do you
guys think has left from the
headquarters like we can see a few
people are still there from like
flashing around between now and like
what's released I have a few thoughts in
mind like well where's tacabra I haven't
seen him since the uh the start of their
conversation I'm pretty sure back at
like 220 something anyway anyway get
back to the story having found a way and
now securing remarks that using reverse
curse technique to heal is exhausted
innate technique looks to restrain his
physical brain quite a bit to him it's
evident that his brain more specifically
the prefrontal cortex for the
information on curse techniques is
located has been destroyed and repaired
far too many times using reverse curse
technique to heal his burnt out curse
technique now oh my God man the amount
of times I have said curse technique
reverse curse technique throughout this
video like I am so confused and I've
probably messed it up like once or twice
I I probably have anyway anyway
terrified at the fact that Golia had
been using such a wild technique used to
just screams that this is way too risky
they all know that the brain especially
that section of the brain is the most
important and you can't even compare it
to Simply repairing someone's normal
bodily damage Shoku speaks up nervous
over the fact that she kind of assumes
by now that Gojo had gotten used to this
effect on his brain however it looks
like he's beginning to suffer on top of
that saguna has actually done it fewer
times so he's in a much healthier better
condition back in Shinjuku and as Gojo
drops to one knee Schooner states that
Gojo has reached his limits even if he
could have expanded his domain again he
would have lost the instant that he did
not to mention the fact that he wouldn't
even be able to make it precise enough
to actually be a threat to sukuna
taunting her like the demon he truly is
so couldn't let gozio know then next up
he'll bring the circumference of his
domain and woods from there he'll be
left with nowhere to run and as he
carves him up he'll simultaneously adapt
to his Infinity saying his final
goodbyes he states that Gojo was born
into an era without sukuna and was
failed as the strongest of that era yet
and the end he just turned out to be
plainfully ordinary saying those
prolific words domain expansion One Last
Time sukuna proceeds to unleash his
domain however in that exact moment all
of his eyes began bleeding profusely and
the domain fails so crazily enough from
the time of the previous domains this
last conversation had happened in 10
seconds and yet just like Gojo sukuna's
brain had sustained enough damage to now
make an expansion impossible jumping up
and laughing at sakona after saying this
God just noticed it it looks like it's
hitting him pretty hard now then
pointing at maze crows he knows that all
of his students are watching him put his
life on the line so he's gonna go ahead
and keep showing off for them jumping
forth with a speed that zakona is unable
to keep up with Gojo throws a fat right
hook to let his opponent know that he
still has a long way to go to defeat him
over inside of the main group's Hideout
kuzukabe asks who there had been
seriously punched by Gojo before a few
people speak pick up nothing there well
he didn't hit them but they tried their
best to punch him as hard as they could
and it was physically impossible due to
only like a few people taking a hit
though kuzakabe who I'm assuming has as
well says that his fists are enhanced
with curse energy and only moments of
impact blue repeatedly absorbs the
surrounding space it feels as if you're
being counter-attacked after preparing
for a regular blow Herrera wonders if it
heard and Hikari along with you to both
reveal that they puked after the head
they took and now we once told Yuji that
if he planned on continuing as a
sorcerer then he shouldn't compare
himself to Gojo he stated that he put a
massive deal of effort behind his
critical hurts but Gojo could casually
perform them as if it was an everyday
thing putting them all back on track
though and what koozakave was mainly
trying to explain was that from here on
out when it comes to straight hands he
doesn't have a clue what Gojo was doing
back in Shinjuku had shown that Gojo is
completely dominating sukuna in a
physical fight he boosts any building
was smashing zakuna into every level
before turning around and tossing them
over the road when zakuna lands Gojo
uses all of the role that had previously
broken away from the building to
interrupt the king of curses and started
break coffin exploding at the reinforced
brick scooter darts forth and quickly
dust a head kick from Gojo getting
caught under his trap though Gojo slams
his leg down only the seats are going to
flip out of the way and prepare his own
ax Kirk all of a sudden he stops though
as he says what seems like Gojo running
at such a high speed it's begun creating
a circle of after images thinking that
he has the upper hand now God Drew darts
and a strike but sukuna manages to spot
the real homage and grab his hand before
following up and punching him straight
in the face being sent backwards Gojo
quickly regains his orientation and lets
you top a nearby street lights walking
towards him sukuna explains that furu's
Incarnation used her like manifest
maharaga along with a will represents
complete circulation and Harmony once
maharaga has been attacked the wheel
turns and the adaption begins with that
said the will turned and Maharaj
uses domain amplification and touches
him the wheel turns black so it's safe
to assume then in his eyes that it
interrupts the adaption process as
tsukuna can't activate his domain but
can use amplification that's probably
because the area of his brain originally
damaged was in charge of barrier
techniques over the sakona now as he
slowly strolls forth he thinks that Gojo
is most likely only using laps to avoid
having his other techniques adapted
which makes perfect sense in his eyes as
the lights then go green the two of them
rushes each other once more clashing in
the middle of the road with a light Gojo
was just on falling behind sakuna he
quickly grabs it and Buffs it towards
Gojo however it freezes as the object
connects with his Infinity they go for
the main group now as they all note that
its random maharaga hasn't reappeared
they suppose that it had already adapted
once unlimited void was used for a fifth
time taking like that knowledge in
Carrie deduces that maybe the wheel has
to turn a few times and order for zacona
to adapt to Gojo's Limitless technique
then just like they assumed and ezekuna
asked if Gojo had been paying attention
to his ability Alman explains that he
needs four spends in total which
technically means only three more spins
of the wheel and to maharaga fully
adapts to kojo's Infinity walking
towards each other again sukuna jokes
that they're now over countdown to win
Gojo's idiotic smirk will be wiped from
his face cause now go to smile right
back and tell him the same damn thing in
fact Gojo takes it one step further
saying that he'll beat him dead before
he even makes it to the third spin still
eagerly watching the battle Hannah
questions if God was just forgotten
about Mega me to watch Yuji says that
man might really have hearing them and
looking ready to throw some hands
himself kashimo jokes that it's fine let
him forget megaming needing to fix it
Mickey because man's in a slightly tight
spot right now Yuji watches as
maharaga's wheel spins for the second
time meaning that there's only two more
spins until Gojo's Infinity will be
fully adapted to turning his hands into
perfectly constructed orbs of blue curse
energy Gojo flings him at tsukuna making
him acrobatically flip out of the way as
the ability burns the bridge from
existence capturing tsukuna within his
range Gojo sticks both of his hands
forth and creates more cursed energy
orbs that Circle his Target leaving them
with nowhere to escape somehow escaping
though sakuna manages to dug down before
darting off causing all of the orbs to
immediately change direction and start
tracking his new position boasting it
around one of the nearby pillars goju
flies up and quickly blocks akuna's Kirk
having gained the advantage now he
follows up by kicking his opponent down
towards the road below while falling the
wheel spins for the third time making
everyone back at the TV room get more
and more nervous over the impending
adaption Yuji curiously wonders if it's
time that's needed for the wheel to
adapt or if it was Battle experience
realizing what yuju was trying to say
kusakave solidifies his question by also
pondering if a does it take one attack
then time for the wheel to understand
then adapt or B as it adapting after
taking multiple blows still no even sure
himself he points out that Gojo hasn't
used anything other than Labs so he
doesn't even know and compounding that
kashimo states that either option is
actually possible that's the reality of
the situation following the king of
curses through one of the nearby
buildings Windows got your remarks that
from now on he's going to give him hell
in his eyes he's convinced zakuna that
all he's using is blue so with this
timing he won't be able to react pulling
up his hand and firing a point-blank
shot of curse technique reversal red
Gojo just watches As the World Turns
black signifying that sakuna had
activated his domain amplification as
the technique hit and because of what I
previously just mentioned sukuna was
just barely able to minimize the damage
in time activating his reverse curse
technique to heal sukuna thinks that he
expected this even Earth amplification
can neutralize the low output of
Limitless it can't fully cancel out blue
or the Reversed red Yuji and kusukabe
both react in abject horror as they
realize that at this rate zakuna will
fully adapt his technique looking
heavily based and amp bruised sakuna
turns around to remark that Gojo is
sloppy and Christians are the greatest
Sorcerer of today had lost his call once
his hand was read randomly though Goji
doesn't attack and instead he just tells
his opponent that you know like the
really shot back before well it hasn't
actually exploded yet suddenly taking
one of the hardest back shots in the
figure of world that is Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
sukuna gasps in pain as he realizes that
hey the king of curses was taken from
behind quickly calculating the
building's layout he figures that Gojo
must have planned from this start to
have red strike after one full lap not
giving him a chance to recover Gojo
follows up and pounds to kuna so damn
hard with a black flash that physically
knocks Akuna out for a moment everyone
back at the TV room just watches an ore
as he never expected such an ability to
land let alone be as successful as it
was back in Shinjuku blood pours from
sakuna's mouth and the wheel Falls
symbolizing the defeat of History
stronger sorcerer randomly though the
wheel picks up speed and Spins for the
final time time while at the exact same
time a stunned Gojo falls into a pool of
darkness and maharaga's demonic hands
reach out for him with nowhere to go
maharaga grabs Gojo and slices his chest
for the sword of extermination leaving
everyone's hope of survival on the brink
of death
beads of sweat drip from everyone's head
as they worry about how things could
have taken a turn for the worse with
Gojo since maharaga like has arrived now
it means that he's completely adapted to
Gojo's technique Yuji however stays
hopeful as in his eyes maharaga only
adapted to the infinity which means it's
only an equal fight now and Gojo can
heal up right away using reverse curse
technique standing nearby and looking
absolutely stressed shoko explains that
she's been smoking a ton during this
battle sadly she thinks it isn't just a
case of healing up a game instead it's
more that Gojo's healing is gradually
becoming slower than usual it was
extended use of red if the already
prolonged Fight Continues and might end
up with him not being able to use his
curse technique reversal to heal as
quickly therefore he could actually lose
though she does pose that that situation
is probably the exact same for sakona
Gojo's opponent is the king of curses
initially when the battle kicked off
everyone thought that it would be
impossible for Gojo to win and now with
what they've seen that thought is slowly
creeping back in even Gojo himself has
begun thinking the same thing wondering
how long it's been since he felt like
this it reminds him of a battle 11 years
earlier against toji fushiguro and how
now he's beginning to feel the same
satisfaction from fighting that's
pushing him to an even higher degree
throughout the special being the
strongest sadly comes with the title of
also being the loneliest and now the
only thing that will truly satisfy him
flying forth God your head to maharago
with a direct hit that pushes the
godchikagami back instantly following up
he tries to activate red in order to
finish him off but sakuna jumps back in
and uses megami's rabbit escape to cover
maharaga and allow him to prepare for
the next attack having watched his
opponent try his best to evade every
attack Gojo moxikuna asking him how long
he's gonna rest for after taking the
black flash and that it was pretty
obvious it's a fix are still hurting him
suddenly sukuna mixes things up and
throws a fire extinguisher to cover
himself and make an opening for maharaga
to attack Gojo as Gojo was caught up in
his fight with biggie game sakuna uses a
new application of migami's Max elephant
chikagami to shoot a blast of water that
mirrors choso's piercing blood technique
just as Gojo defends himself against
maharaga so could his attack lands and
wounds his arm flying backwards Dodger
realizes that tsukuna is mainly waiting
for his Infinity ability to vanish
meaning that the fight would eventually
turn into a pure 2V1 if it continues
annoyed he wonders how sakuna is even
able to use the abilities of the
tsukigami without summoning them in the
first place like me has to go through
this whole procedure where sukuna can
wear the wheel and summon the shikagami
with what I'm assuming are just his
thoughts here Gojo knows that sensokuna
was able to adapt to his Infinity
ability he's gonna have to use more
curse energy that's why he's been
simultaneously using the shukigami
however he does explain that asakuna
wants to adapt to red and will take much
longer to do so katina's brainstorming
off though sakuna beams his way back
into the picture while stating that this
isn't a 1v2 numpty I'm the fraudulent
one moving his hands together Sakura
summons a brain brand new shikagami cold
the Chimera based agito making this
previously 2V1 a now 3v1 battle and
putting Gojo even further onto the back
foot according to take what I've seen
online and everything since the chapter
drop Chimera base is a mixture of new
way and totality which is probably a
combination that I never actually saw
coming and leave so many other weird and
wacky hybrids up of creation of the
future but obviously you know moving
forward go your own self even jokes that
with those two Giants standing there
sakuna looks like a lost child and a
flash the two beasts so they fight once
more with Gojo just barely being able to
dodge the initial attacks randomly and
stealing some more of megami's
techniques sakuna pops out of the audio
Shadows with his hands aimed like a
pistol and shoot another water blast
like piercing blood from Max elephant's
ability but Gojo Dodges there too Simon
is fists down Gojo just misses as
tsukuna backflips out of the way
allowing his boys to follow up with a
dual Hawk from either side somehow
dodging each of these large creatures
and arriving behind maharaga Gojo
proceeds to blast him with red but it's
barely even effective enough to burn the
creature now figuring that man's
probably stuffed if he doesn't do
something completely insane here Goji
deduces there he has to use this damn
technique in order to be able to finish
off maharaga in one shot at a massive
risk as tsukuna will most likely notice
the raised output but it's a risk he's
willing to take with a glimmer of hope
and a cheeky grin on his face Gojo
states that he's got no other choice
it's time to use the unlimited Hollow
technique I don't know about everyone
else here but things had exactly looking
good for Gojo at the moment kind of goes
over if you catch my drift unless this
insane technique of his works in the
next chapter we might be in for another
heartbreaking death which as we all know
is something gigay doesn't hold back on
at all and I I really hope mapper does
well with Shibuya what should be
dropping like next weekend I'm pretty
sure the entire Lake calling sakona
fraudulent is a great meme but dude
right now seems to be implementing
cursed energy in a way that we've never
even seen it get used before even Gojo
was confused with how man's able to
activate
abilities without hand signals or even
saying anything have you guys did enjoy
this fight and want to keep up to date
which is due to Kaizen in general though
then make sure to subscribe and be sure
to leave a like as it truly helps out
with bringing a bunch of new people to
this channel again thanks for 170 000
subscribers be sure to check out the
patreon if you want to get slightly
earlier access to my videos and
everything but for now it's been your
professional degenerate dear Volo and I
will see you all in eight Birds bye